yeah well so
uh i guess my game isn't very
entertaining so
i might as well try to entertain in
another way um i think
yeah he surprised me a bit in the
opening with uh
this idea c5 queen a5
and i ended up playing uh in the most
obvious way and
basically let him eat my bishop and
after that uh
there's not much to do
but i think i need to try um
one of a few ways i think after queen
take c5
maybe a3 was interesting there forcing
bishop c3 queen c3
and now the point is there's no d5 so
first of all if 94 queen e3 is a good
ending so he probably castles there
and now i can
try maybe f3
um with the idea to get e4 and at least
here it's uh it's a game i i have two
bishops and
if i can get um developed with e4 bishop
d392 it looks pretty good so yeah i mean
that was just one continuation that
i probably needed to try because uh
yeah in general this is you know not
really
the kind of chess i want to be playing
so yeah it just goes to show that uh you
have to take a little bit of risk to uh
to pose problems here so
uh lesson learned
lesson learned said jeffrey